hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
franz fonon's work black skin white
masks
is a work of psychoanalytic theory but
it's also
you could say oriented just as equally
by
existentialist motifs and they kind of
fuse
in together so some of the
key questions that fanon is raising
in the work or that of you know what is
actually the the situation
trying to peel away misrepresentations
of the the relations between blacks and
whites and
and why this alienation that he's he's
describing early on in the work is
taking place and how
these are connected together so he calls
this a socio-diagnostic
of the of the situation we could call it
a sociodiagnostic of the present
he's not so much interested in tracing
everything back to you know
the past and this mechanistically caused
this or anything like that
although he does think the past matters
and then the other
key aspect of this work is determining
how and where to move forward how to get
out of the
dilemmas and double or triple binds that
have been
imposed upon both black and white
subjects and people who find themselves
kind of in between like him and his
fellow antilleans
within a world that has been determined
by colonialism racism economic
exploitation
an entire history how do you move
forward how do you go into
the future how do you orient yourself
towards the future
without becoming as he's called it a
slave
of the past and there's there's two
sections in this work that i think are
particularly
relevant to this one is of course his
his conclusion
uh which is uh titled uh
by way of conclusion at the very end
chapter eight but also
chapter five the fact of blackness where
he's tracing out a little bit of his own
story in here and so we should look
first at
chapter five where this this counter
narrative
is being developed and
explored and he goes into you know quite
a bit of uh
important discussion about how this
takes place
a sort of celebration of african
past and present and it's really taking
place
in in two different ways there's this
notion of well
africa is is not a land without history
as the europeans
have made it out to be as a matter of
fact there's all these civilizations
you know we developed this we did this
and there the wii there is kind of
a it's a collective but it's also
as fanon would say kind of hallucinatory
a a
fake but imaginative we because it
africa is a continent of peoples like
every other
place you know these categories of black
and white
uh imposed through colonialism largely
don't make everybody exactly you know
one
members of one big tribe or family so
so there's this this celebration of
we could call it africa's past
right and then there's this sort of
present that's being focused on but it's
a present
that is in many respects not a
uh historically present present but
rather like an eternal present
talking about essences of
peoples and he's got these phrases
he talks about magic at a couple
different
points and i think this is this is quite
an
amped way of discussing things so you
know he talks
about reading leopold senor and the
importance of rhythm and
the experience of of thinking about this
he says had i read that right
i read it again with redouble detention
from the opposite war
end of the white world so like whites
are at one core
end of the spectrum a magical negro
culture was hailing me
negro sculpture i began to flush with
pride was this our salvation
i had rationalized the world and the
world that rejected me on the basis of
color prejudice since no agreement was
possible on the level of reason
i threw myself back towards unreason and
we see like stances like this
not just with with fanon but with all
sorts of people where they're like
well you know western rationality
whiteness all that sort of stuff
that's you know missing out on what's
really essential in human beings this
other ethnicity whatever it happens to
be
they're they're more in touch with the
primal with what's what's really
human and so he's exploring stuff like
this in terms of trying to make sense
out of his
own you know conflicts
and so he says out of the necessities of
my struggle i'd chosen the method of
negre
of regression but it was an unfamiliar
weapon here i am at home
i am made of the irrational i weighed in
the
irrational um and so he goes on and
there's there's
you know some long passages here i'm
going to skip ahead
quite a bit it talks about um emotive
sensitivity
and that leopold senor is saying
that or yeah that um emotion
is is negro reason is greek and we've
seen these sort of things all the time
right
in the past this is leopold senor sort
of channeling other people and so he
says
so here we have the negro rehabilitated
standing before the bar
ruling the world with his intuition the
negro recognized said on his feet
against sought after taken up
and he has a negro no he is not a negro
but the negro exciting the fee conde
antenna of the world placed in the fore
ground of the world reigning his poetic
power on the world
you know all this sort of stuff and
here he talks about a magic substitution
right and he says um
like a magician i've robbed the white
man of a certain world forever after
loss to him and his and
now does this actually change anything
and
is it good to like indulge oneself in
these things
funona actually says i'm not going to
say that nobody can do it
but ultimately it doesn't really make
any difference it doesn't help
anything the rediscovery of african
civilizations
is not going to particularly help as
well he says
i rummaged frantically through all the
antiquity of the black man
what i found there took away my breath
in his book la bellission de lis lavage
shulker presented us with compelling
arguments since then for benius
westerman delafoss
all of them white had joined the chorus
segu degene
cities of more than a hundred thousand
people accounts of learned blacks
doctors of
theology who went to mecca to interpret
the quran
all of that assumed from the past spread
with its insides out
made it possible for me to find a valid
historic place
the white man was wrong i was not a
primitive
not even a half man i belong to a race
that already been working in gold and
silver 2000 years ago
and so you know this is another there's
a lot more discussion here
as well this is another approach so
we've got sort of magical
eternalist approach right there's the
black essence the white essence and then
we've got the historical approach that
says
well as a matter of fact there there was
you know civilization in africa and this
is true
this is this is accurate right some of
the claims
made by by some people who go a little
bit far that like all the egyptians were
black or stuff like that clearly
historically
you know uh unfounded and fun owen would
you know if he were around hearing that
sort of stuff he would have said well
i don't know about that what i do know
is that you know
there were these things in sub-saharan
africa that were
quite developed civilizations we can say
something quite similar about native
americans here
as well think about the you know
civilizations that arose and
you know archaeology finds them we're
here right now in the middle
of uh here in milwaukee and further
south to chicago what was an
immense trading network right on
you know recently uncovered
um does that really change anything
discovering these things and
fanon says no and so he talks about the
problematics of what he calls the
dialectic what is the dialectic
it's thinking things through thinking
about whether
talking about you know all these
discoveries changes the
current dynamic of the present
and so he says is on a little bit after
that section he says
my unreason was countered with reason my
reason with real reason
every hand was a losing hand for me i
analyzed my heredity
i made a complete audit of my ailment i
wanted to be typically negro it was no
longer possible
i couldn't make that recourse
i wanted to be white that was a joke and
when i tried on the level of ideas
and intellectual activity to reclaim my
negritude it was snatched away from me
proof was presented that my effort was
only a
term in the dialectic and again he
brings up
jean-paul sartre who's talking about
senor
and existentialism in in some respect
is making him distrustful of these
essentialist
approaches a little bit later on in that
section
he says that without a negro past
without a negro future it was impossible
for me to live
my neighborhood not yet white yet no
longer holy
black i was damned between the white man
and me the connection was
in irrevocably one of transcendence
and then he says something kind of
interesting he says but the constancy of
my love had been forgotten
i defined myself as an absolute
intensity of beginning
so i took up my negritude and with tears
in my eyes i put its machinery together
again would have been broken to pieces
was rebuilt
reconstructed by the intuitive liana's
vines of my hands
and so this you know is allowing him a
reconstruction we can say
not all this has to be absolutely
rejected and thrown away
but it has to be critically
reappropriated so
when we look at that by way of a
conclusion
what we get is a consideration of
history
or the orientation to the past and he
says
you know what i'm saying
here uh doesn't necessarily
come from the same mindset as the negro
working on a sugar plantation
who has to fight and he says
the few working class people who i had
the chance to know in paris
never took it on themselves to pose the
discovery of the
negro past they knew they were black but
they told me that made no difference in
anything in which they were absolutely
right discovery of this this legendary
past
it doesn't change the the living
conditions it doesn't change the racism
they're encountering
it doesn't help anything i mean it might
be interesting it might give one a sense
of pride
but it doesn't it doesn't change
anything in
a fundamental way a little bit later on
he has this excellent uh
discussion of this
where he talks about children and he
says that
here we go i am convinced it would be of
the greatest interest to be able to have
contact with the negro literature or
architecture of the third century before
christ
i would be happy to know that a
correspondence had flourished between
some negro philosopher and plato
but i can absolutely not see how this
fact
would change anything in the lives of
the eight-year-old children who labor in
the cane fields
of martinique or guadalupe how does that
that past and all these great
discoveries
how does that change their material
conditions it doesn't
it doesn't impact it in any way as a
matter of fact it could actually make
them
feel worse they could be like why do i
live in this crappy condition now
right so the the the focus on the past
as he says
doesn't provide any helpful guidance
in the present says the discovery of the
existence of a negro civilization in the
15th century
confers no patent of humanity on me like
it or not
the past can in no way guide me in the
present moment and he talks about
becoming a slave to the past becoming a
slave to a particular interpretation
of the human past and then being stuck
in this sort of cycle of wanting to
attain some sort of rectification or
revenge he says
the problem considered here is one of
time those negroes and white men will be
dis-alienated
who refuse to let themselves be sealed
away in the materialized tower of the
past
and so for many uh he talks about this
as
i don't have a purpose on earth as
avenging the negro of the 17th century
i don't have to be uh you know trying to
to to do this as a he says i as a man of
color i don't have the right to seek
ways of stamping down the pride of my
former master i neither of the right or
duty to claim reparation for the
domestication of my
ancestors and this is going quite far
this is where i think a lot of people
would
leave fanon behind
and you know his response would be i am
not the slave of the slavery
that dehumanized my ancestors i i may be
trapped in you know circumstances of the
present but they're not the
circumstances of the past
and i need to recognize that so i'm not
just replicating
an alternate history of the past which
is
in many respects uh just as delusional
as the you know fake white histories
of uh you know the past was just fine
and everything went along swimmingly
right so this is an important thing but
what what then do we have his
orientation he talks about this
disalienation
in this this point and he also says that
those negroes and white men who are
going to be disalienated
this alienation will come into being
through refusal to accept the presence
as definitive so not even the conditions
of the present can be taken
for granted we have to have an
orientation towards towards something
else something more
and he uses as an example the revolts
taking place
in at that time indochina right against
the
the french and he says well why are the
vietnamese
rising up against them it's not because
they discovered some vietnamese culture
of the past
as they're like this present sucks we're
not going to put up with it anymore
fighting against the japanese has really
shown us that
we can probably take out the french as
well
so he says it's not because the
indochinese has discovered a culture of
zone
in that he's in revolt it's because
quite simply it was
in more than one way becoming impossible
for him to breathe
right um and so
he talks about revolt as as something
that is a rejection of the present
it says the vietnamese who die before
the firing squads are not hoping that
their sacrifice will bring about the
reappearance of a past
it is for the sake of a present and of
the future
they're willing to die so he thinks that
this can be
used to understand decolonialization
in in general he also talks about this
is
a very interesting point he's got this
assertion
there is no negro mission there is no
white burden
i find myself suddenly in a world in
which things do evil a world in which
i'm summoned into battle
a world in which it's always a question
of annihilation or triumph
i find myself in a world where words
wrap themselves in silence where the
other endlessly hardens himself
my life is caught on the lasso of
existence
my freedom turns me back on himself on
myself
i do not have the duty to be this or
that
and so he's talking he began the book by
talking about a sort of humanism
humanism embraces humanity
as a race
as a problematic composed of people
who've
oppressed each other and continue to do
so in terms of all sorts of things
in in you know our recent history race
is
is one of those so he's rejecting this
idea of there being for him
a negro mission as well as of the white
the white man's burden as it was called
um
he also goes on and talks about rights
and duties what does he have the right
and duty to do
he says i find myself suddenly in the
world and i recognize i have one right
alone
that of demanding human behavior from
the other
so now this sounds as if he's getting
away from race entirely he's not though
um you know the entire book is is
carrying out this diagnosis but
it has to lead to something that does go
beyond just
reinforcing races against each other he
goes on as well and he says i have one
duty alone
that of not renouncing my freedom
through my
choices now here's where the
existentialism comes in right
that is is prototypically existential is
maintaining freedom you can see this
insert and duvoir
and so many others in in cambo in marcel
right and he goes on and he affirms a
kind
of solidarity at this point i should
also
point out this other passage i should
constantly remind myself the real leap
consists in introducing invention into
existence
in the world through which i travel i'm
endlessly creating myself i'm part of
being to the degree
that i go beyond it and so he says
this is indeed the problem of action
i have to decide what i am going to do
in this presence and i have to do so
he says as as a black man
but i my situation is not unique in this
respect
right so demanding human behavior of the
other that's
a good place to close upon that is going
to produce conflict that is going to
generate others saying oh you've got it
wrong for you know whether they're
they're people who
are pro-colonialism and pro-racism or
people
who are anti-but also think that fanon
is maybe capitulating too much right
there's multiple perspectives possible
for those who want to exhibit some sort
of solidarity and live out an ethical
and in this view existentialist life
so fanon is exposing himself to that and
that is the position that he's taking
about
how to move forward and why doesn't he
have a complete program in place
precisely because he's an existentialist
because he thinks people have to take
responsibility
within the situations that they find
themselves in which are going to be
different
in 1970 in 1990 in 2020
than they were at the time that he's
writing this
but there is a coherent
program here and one that relates itself
to
these these other what he considers to
be mistaken paths
for understanding the relations between
blacks and whites
you